at tyneside Cinema in Newcastle the last
few years have been difficult it's the
only independent cinema left in the
Northeast and its future is uncertain
Rising energy costs are pushing business
to the brink the picture is is really
really Stark I mean to sort of underline
the numbers that are behind this you
know we've seen a 300 rise in in our
utility costs this year which you know
is creates an enormous hole in the
budget of an organization like ours and
we're still in a position where you know
we're on sort of about a 40 shortfall in
terms of audience levels versus
pre-pandemic
founded in 1937 the cinema has a rich
cultural history if it closes its doors
the loss will be felt here this Cinema
is incredibly important and it's
somewhere that I really enjoy coming to
even on my own a lot of money has been
spent on it I'm sure there's lots of
people who would who very much Miss it
it's very precious this Cinema and
hopefully it will survive lots of small
cinemas around the country are facing
similar struggles last year the
lighthouse in Wolverhampton and
edinburgh's filmhouse shut their doors
for good others could follow I think all
Cinemas and indeed all businesses were
grateful for the support that government
provided when energy costs started to
spike in in Spring of last year and and
the continuation of that support through
into the beginning of 2023 was was
hugely welcome clearly businesses like
Cinemas and others face to Cliff Edge at
the end of March when support finished
the government says its support for
businesses was unprecedented but for a
sector Under Pressure it's hard not to
reminisce because it hasn't always been
this way even alongside streaming Cinema
carried on doing really well between
2010 and 2020 the number of Cinemas in
the country grew by 15 but then came
covid and now Rising energy costs
reversing that Trend the cinemas don't
want to see the curtain close a final
time after all Cinema goes beyond what's
on the big screen it's a place for the
community Aisha zahid Sky News